make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay what's up members of the robber
Corps you know I thought about making
you guys wait like weeks for the
conclusion of spawn Armageddon for no
other reason than the fact that I could
I even did a poll on Twitter I was like
should I should I make you guys wait or
should I cover it now and it was kind of
crazy like half of almost half of the
guys were like just make us wait and I
was like what I was like what I that
that's that's not how this was supposed
to go you were supposed to like be like
no we need it now and then you know like
post gifts but you guys didn't it was a
little bit disappointing but we are here
covering the conclusion of spawn
Armageddon and as we know spawn up to
this issue has basically destroyed all
life on Earth with the exception of God
and Satan right they're the only two
individuals left everything else is
essentially dead and that's kind of the
crazy thing about this because when all
this goes down you give that God and
Satan who are almost kind of like taken
by surprise like spawn the protector of
humanity has basically eradicated all
beings in existence from the plate from
the face of the earth it really is just
a dead desolate world right all life all
gone is there's just nothing here
initially the thought is that like spawn
was crying over what is it he'd done
only for us to find out that spawns
actually laughing and the reason why is
because he's actually mocking God and
Satan he's like well you guys had this
plan going on for thousands of years
right you created people and then people
started going divvying up at a different
groups good guys and bad guys some of
them want to Satan's if someone went to
God and this was all supposed to go into
some great big huge grand battle you
know some grand conflict that the two of
you guys are going to fight for however
long it was going to be to determine
which of you is truly the strongest and
I brought the whole thing to an end like
that you know so like what is this
saying about like you guys this is all
just one big joke it's literally giving
God and Satan a hard time and so in
response they they kind of ask the
question like you're just a hell spawn
right like you're essentially just kind
of like a soldier of hell
how did you manage to pull all this off
you know and and basically like the
mother of creation pops up and says like
he's what I made him to be following
that God gets pissed God's like you
b-word it basically you know this is the
this is the friendly stuff if you want
to see the uncensored videos go to
patreon.com/scishow come explain that's
where you get all the uncensored stuff
like Punisher match that we're covering
which is gonna be which is fun and
awesome and totally needs to be
uncensored
but nonetheless you know from there when
the mother of creation is sort of Jasper
chastised by God and seen right like you
can't do this of course the mother of
creation freaks out says you know I I do
what I will and then spawn says there's
actually something you can do for me and
when the mother of creation asked what
it is spawn says these two kids look too
much like Wanda change them into their
true forms I want to see what they truly
look like and that's what we see what
God in Satan actually really looked like
in the spawn universe they're naked but
they don't have any junk so that's I
guess that's okay what God and Satan
have genitalia that really is the we ask
the serious questions here at commis
explained we asked the hard-hitting
questions here but nonetheless you know
from there it's almost kind of like
their desire to it to really kind of
instigate a conflict with spawn right
and spawn was warned by the mother of
creation understand by having them in
these childlike forms it curves the
desire for like death and destruction
and all those different things by
turning them back into their regular
forms they will have a level of death
and destruction that you're not quite
ready for they will have a level of
power that you could challenge but
you're not really capable of going
toe-to-toe with at the moment it would
simply just take time and spawns
response is whatever man like if these
guys really believe that they have what
it takes to take me out then let them do
their worst and so following that they
basically blast spawn and spawn gets
taken out right here he says it is
finished spawn is essentially destroyed
right so this great big huge climactic
battle that's been building up between
spawn and like God and Satan happens
with a quickness and that's basically it
and that's when the mother of creation
asked are you content now are you happy
now that was the last of the human race
these beans you had the power to create
you destroyed right that's all you guys
are good for is just destroying things
and that therein is the the very nature
of the mother of creations
disappointment with her creation of God
and Satan all they do is destroy and
it's why she considered them to be
failures and so for a moment there's
almost kind of like this sort of
reprieve where Satan of all people is
kind of like man like you know we're
gods like is this what we've come to and
Satan's kinda like yeah ma'am maybe we
should kind of rethink things and then
immediately God turns on Satan and says
this is your fault and that's when
everything kind of devolves right back
down to where it was before God created
humanity and humanity were basically
oblivious to everything around them
right they just kind of existed they had
no knowledge of good and evil
then Satan Priya presented Eve with the
with the apple of the knowledge of good
and evil she consumed it and then gave
it to Adam and then Adam consumed it and
then they had knowledge of good and evil
and free will is what came from that and
so following that they basically bent to
their base desires and that's where the
the argument gets intriguing right
because if all Satan did was basically
say here's knowledge of good and evil
then did Satan really do anything to
make humanity evil or did he give him an
e the ability to choose which decided
wanted and then humanity chose to become
evil like humanity chose that role they
bent to their inherent desires it's kind
of intruding there because when it comes
to good and evil I remember learning
this lesson and Star Wars Knights of the
Old Republic of all games that the path
to goodness is usually much much harder
than the path to evil now the path to
evil is more fun during nights the order
of public I was a dick like I was I was
using my force powers on everyone I was
just like like I were there's this one
chick on Tatooine she's like we really
need this raid plate and like can you
please and I was like give me that and I
was like thank you I'll what is it I
said my need is greater than yours and
just took it I was like I was a terrible
person everybody played the dark side
first and don't even get me in that
nonsense about how you play the light
side first you didn't you play the dark
side first nobody chose them nobody
chooses the light side Jedi suck but
nonetheless it's kind of fun here it's
kind of crazy because following this God
and Satan basically just kind of
devolved down into this full-on battle
with each other and while that's
happening spawn had essentially been
saved by the mother of creation and what
she basically tells him here is this is
the nature of God and Satan they will
fight for all eternity right they're
evenly matched and they are immortal
they're never going to be able to
overcome the other and that's kind of a
nature of good and evil and that's one
of the cool things about this right
because you cannot have one without the
other you cannot have goodness without
the antithesis in the form of evil
because it's only with evil that
understanding the value of goodness
comes into play and so because of that
you know spawn is really kind of like
what do we do here at this point right I
mean the earth is all devoid of life
there's nothing here anymore like what
do we do and the mother of creation says
you can recreate everything right this
earth is basically gone this earth is
gone and done now it's the the territory
of God and Satan they're gonna fight on
it forever right as long as they believe
humanity's been destroyed they're just
gonna fight against each other for ever
and ever and ever and never
really overcome the other right it's
just what's going to happen until the
end of time or until they destroy their
world or whatever the case is but you Al
Simmons have the ability to recreate you
have the ability to give birth to
everything and so this is really an in
kind of a misnomer from the last video
this is really the full totality of
divine spawns power because using the
help of the mother of creation spawn
essentially recreates all existence
spawn literally recreates the earth and
all humanity in it but the funny thing
about this is that instead of stripping
them of their knowledge of the end of
days of the apocalypse he grants them
that information because what it does is
it gives humanity the knowledge the
absolute true and undeniable knowledge
that there is something out there
greater than themselves and it's only
ever when humanity as a whole is
presented with a threat that one person
or one one country or civilization
cannot overcome on its own that people
usually work together in order to quell
that threat it may be a temporary thing
but what this means here is that in
order for Humanity to truly achieve
great things you have to have a coming
together of civilization as a whole
everyone who's alive here remembers the
Four Horsemen walking the earth right
they remember pestilence and death and
famine and and war walking the face of
the planet all the things they went
through dates they remember what it
meant to die they remember what it meant
to become miss soldiers of health and
the soldiers of heaven they recall their
experiences with all of these things and
so what this means is that one when Al
Simmons is presented with the notion of
are you going to allow Heaven and Hell
to still have access to this he
immediately says no Heaven and Hell
basically are cut off to earth they can
never enter earth they can never leave
earth they can have no involvement with
humanity in any form or fashion
following that the question is what are
you going to do right because at the
moment spawn is God right that's what he
is now what are you gonna do with all
this power spawn and that's when he says
I initially came back for Wanda right
this is all going full circle I came
back for Wanda I made that bargain with
mal Bhoja I chose to be a hell spawn
because I wanted to have Wanda back I
wanted her in my life and I would do
whatever I needed to do in order to make
that happen and this is where things are
kind of cool right there's CSI you
tilled in between a guy who can who can
like get done and a guy who's just like
man I really hope things go my way
spawns just like okay so here's my
situation right now Wanda
that was dead but now she knows and I'm
alive but she married Terry after she
believed that I was dead and then like
they kind of did their whole thing
together so like sorry about your luck
Terry I'm taking my girl back that's
basically what this is he's like I want
to be reborn as our seven scuzz at the
end of the day Wanda loves Terry sure
she loves him but she'll never love him
as much as she loves me so like mister
steal yo girl is back I guess not really
steal your girl mister steal your girl
back you know steal his girl back I
guess is what it is
but unless spawn basically rolls up and
says like I'm going home right like I do
not want this power of God take this
away from me I don't want to have
anything to do with this I just want to
go back and be a normal man now
initially the mother of creation goes to
kind of issue a warning but spawn is
like there is no more spawn I don't want
to hear any anything about this I don't
want to hear anything you have to say I
am just gonna go home without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are no year to come this
explained it make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the rod
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and that will catch
you all later
purse
[Music]
you